THIS YEAR.
A SPOKESMAN SAID HIS CLIENT AND
HIS ATTORNEYS ARE REVIEWING THE
NEW CHARGES.
MEN   HE HAS MAINTAINED HIS INNC
MEN   HE HAS MAINTAINED HIS INNN
MEN   HE HAS MAINTAINED HIS INNE
MEN   HE HAS MAINTAINED HIS INN.
A LONG-TIME SECURITY DIRECTOR
FOR HIS KEY SENATE COMMITTEE IS
IN SERIOUS LEGAL TROUBLE
TONIGHT.
WE HAVE THE AMAZING STORY OF
JAMES WOLF.
>> THE TERM SECURITY DIRECTOR
MAY NOT NEW JUSTICE TO JAMES
WOLF'S ROLE AT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE FOR SELECTED
INTELLIGENCE.
ANY DOCUMENT SENT TO THAT
COMMITTEE WAS RECEIVED BY WOLF
AND ENTIRELY MAINTAINED BY WOLF.
HE MADE HIS FIRST COURT
APPEARANCE TODAY, CHARGED WITH
THREE COUNTS OF LYING TO
INVESTIGATORS.
HE WAS RELEASED ON PERSONAL
RECOGNIZANCE AND HAD TO
RELINQUISH HIS PASSPORT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CONVINCED HIS
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS TRACKED
DOWN A MAJORLY CORRECT.
>> President Trump: IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT LEAKER.
SO IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
I'M GETTING INFORMATION NOW, AND
IT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT AND IT
COULD BE A TERRIFIC THING.
>> THE FBI DOES NOT ACCUSE HIM
OF LEAKING CLASSIFIED INFO BUT
INSTEAD MAKING FALSE STATEMENTS
TO FBI AGENTS ABOUT HIS
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FOUR
JOURNALISTS.
ONE OF WHOM IS ALI WATKIN'S, NOW
WITH "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
IDENTIFIED IN THE INDICTMENT AS
REPORTER NUMBER TWO.
THE INDICTMENT CITES AN ARTICLE
WRITTEN BY HER PREVIOUSLY AT
BUZZFEED.
AND WOLF DENIED KNOWING ABOUT
THE REPORTERS SOURCES FOR THE
ARTICLE.
FBI AGENTS CONFRONTED WOLF WITH
PICTURES SHOWING WOLF TOGETHER
WITH REPORTER NUMBER TWO.
AFTER BEING CONFRONTED, WOLF
ADMITTED TO THE FBI AGENTS THAT
HE HAD LIED TO THEM, AND HE HAD
ENGAGED IN A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH REPORTER
NUMBER TWO SINCE 2014, BUT
MAINTAINED THAT HE HAD NEVER
DISCLOSED TO REPORTER NUMBER TWO
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
IN A JOINT STATEMENT, THE SENATE
UNTIL COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND
RANKING MEMBERS SAID QUOTE THIS
FORMER STAFFERS AND
COMMISSIONERS ON THE STOMACHS OF
MORE THAN THREE DECADES WITH
DISTINCTION.
WOLF EXCHANGE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
WITH REPORTER NUMBER TWO ON THE
ENCRYPTED APPLICATIONS SIGNAL
AND WHATSAPP.
THE FBI GAINED ACCESS TO THAT
DATA BY SEIZING REPORTER
WATKINS' EMAIL AND PHONE
RECORDS.
>> President Trump: I'M A BIG,
BIG BELIEVER IN FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS BUT I'M ALSO A BELIEVER IN
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
IT HAS TO REMAIN CLASSIFIED.
>> Reporter: THE CASE NOW PUTS
TWO BEDROCK PRINCIPLES AGAINST
EACH OTHER, THE GOVERNMENTS NEED